all right we are now live it looks like
yeah Ariel in this new YouTube studio
interface this beta so this is my AMA or
ask me anything session hopefully we'll
have some people showing up in just a
bit to ask some questions not quite you
know a hundred percent on on how to use
this new interface effectively so that's
why I didn't do a link to it ahead of
time earlier but this is my monthly AMA
my ask me anything session so here's
where people get to ask me all sorts of
questions make sure that you know you
don't like swamp the the thing with too
many questions I want everybody to
hopefully get a chance try to get your
questions in early as well because by
the time that we get to the end of these
sessions I usually do about an hour and
a half there's usually a whole string of
questions that have been asked that I
haven't been able to get through the
later ones and I know that a lot of
people like to do some chit chat with
each other in the side streams but you
know try to be civil with each other I
see some some people getting quite
worked up about some of the questions
and answers so if you got some questions
for me all right we already got one here
and so I'll start with that disciple of
rah what are my favorite sci-fi books so
I guess if I had to like pick individual
books I would say you know one of my
favorite authors is philip k dick and i
still think that man in the high castle
used to be my absolute favorite of his
but I think Scanner Darkly now is is
even more a favorite of his what have I
been reading lately you know I
I do this worlds of speculative fiction
series at one of the local libraries
that do it every month and this year one
of the big one of the big series that I
really enjoyed rereading because I
hadn't read it since I was a kid where
the door sigh stories by Gordon Dixon
those those are quite fun very
philosophically involved
I also liked CJ Cera's stories you know
the the Alliant Alliance Union universe
that I read we did we do that earlier
this year last year I think we did that
last year so that was a lot of fun so
yeah that gives you some idea let's look
at the next one
dan the man hey dr. Sadler I'm in my
senior year I'm in the process of
writing my senior philosophy paper do
you have any thoughts or tips so I don't
have any like thoughts or tips when it
comes to like content but I do yeah you
have some some thoughts and tips that
could be kind of helpful in terms of
like structure and what to do in the
paper that might raise your your grade a
bit if the instructor is kind of on the
ball and meant some of them may not be
depending on who you've got teaching so
I think that it's it's you know one of
the things that we do in philosophy that
that we learn to do without a lot of
instruction in it but it is quite
important is make good distinctions so
when you're when you're saying I'm
criticizing XYZ you should say I'm
criticizing this I'm not I'm not
criticizing this and if you're
criticizing them for point XY and Z
indicate which you think is the most
damning criticism you know don't be
don't engage in hyperbolic statements
like it Nietzsche was the worst
philosopher ever and here's why or
something like that you want to be able
to say you know you want to be able to
say where things fit in with
each other you want to you know show
that you have a sense of perspective and
that you thought things out that's
that's quite important so let me take
some of the things that just came up
John French says thanks for the
information you're quite welcome three
by four architecture love the new Marcel
stuff oh so the stuff over the summer on
Marcel's essay very important essay if
you want understand Gabriella Marcel on
the ontological mystery it's actually
get a longer title that by the way was a
presentation to the society sociated day
to feel this week in Marseille and the I
don't think the French version has ever
fully been completely translated with
Blondell and bread here and a couple
other people's remarks on it and then
Marcel's responses to it so alright
let's see Wesley asked what is Sandler's
aesthetics theory I don't have an
aesthetic theory I I don't really have
many theories of my own and in any case
right I'm not I'm not a particularly
original philosopher and I I don't
really intend to be let's see three by
four architecture last AMA I asked you
if you'd cover any early high degree
said being in time readed as really as
it gets please retract I don't even know
what you're asking
being in time is early stuff what would
you want from before being in time you
know
Heidegger you've got like his works
occupy like a whole shelf and most of
the really cool stuff is after being in
time like his you know various lectures
and then all these later writings I'm
not sure what you'd be looking for solq
success what
you think of Berkeley's book the
analysts I don't know that book so then
Charles Millar well get another
disappointing answer have you read any
John Gray I found his straw dogs and
seven types of atheism very interesting
no I haven't I haven't read him other
than a brief like blog entry where he's
talking about his seven types of atheism
that I posted a long a long time ago I
do actually have the book because I have
a client who who sent me he read the
book and he sent the book to me saying
here you go so I'll probably read it
when the semester is over this semester
I'm teaching seven classes and I have my
clients and I have you know editing for
Stoicism today and I'm organizing the
stoical on X conference here in
Milwaukee and doing a lot of public
speaking so I probably won't get to a
lot of new reading outside of class
stuff any time soon ap what is the
difference between Spinoza's and
whiteheads gods so that's a really big
picture question I would say you know
this is gonna be kind of a wrong answer
but in a way it's not Spinoza's God is
more static than whiteheads God and you
could ask a similar question well what
about you know Spinoza's God and Hegel's
God quoi spirit you know Spinoza there's
really there he does have some
historical discussions in the tract
honest theological politicus but there's
no conception of like history itself is
meaningful for human beings I would say
in Spinoza whereas there is for Hegel
and certainly there's I don't know about
history for Whitehead you're thinking
like process in reality right but
certainly God is something that is
developing over time and has connections
with with human beings so I think that
that's probably a way to think of it by
buying in 13 in the consolation of
philosophy
could you explain how boëthius
reconciles God's foreknowledge
reconciles it with human free will
I loved your video but it's still hard
for me to understand so be theist has a
couple different strategies there and
I'll just talk about one and it's one
that he has in common with Augustine
before him and with Ansem after him who
by the way and these monastic libraries
would have had boëthius and Augustine
and also some you know likes bits of
Cicero and Seneca and people like that
so the idea is we often call it
eternalism if you think about time you
know we often picture it to ourselves as
kind of like a timeline right so there's
past in the back however you're
arranging it future and then there's
that little sliver of the present and
it's kind of moving along sort of like
when you're watching a video or podcast
there's that little thing that goes
along there and so you know we're
constantly adding more to the past and
sort of consuming the future with this
little node of the president that's the
way we view things and when we make free
decisions we're making them at that
point in time they may have some
determination from the decisions that we
made previously you know obviously all
sorts of things go into factoring into
the decisions that we make now the
problem that arises is it's one that
arises when you have gods or a God who
can see the future by the way this comes
up in cicero's on fate and on divination
and you know things like that as well so
this is not a a purely you know
Christian problem if they can see the
future doesn't that mean that the future
is then determined so then when I'm
getting to that point I'm not really
making a free decision right it's
already been set ahead of time and you
know Anselm and louisia sand and
Augustine and they say well yeah God
sees you God sees you making a free
decision it's part of the nature of the
will that's part of the other answer to
it but let's just think about the
timeline thing so god doesn't have a
timeline God sees the entire thing
all at once as real because God exists
in eternity and eternity is like one
this is metaphorical one big present
that encompasses all of the presence and
your mind my boggle thinking about well
how the hell does that work
you know how can he possibly understand
all these things or know all these
things and well you know it's it we
theist says yes this is hard to
understand right why is it hard to
understand because you know the divine
is actually relying upon a like higher
level of intelligence than what we
ourselves as human beings are used to
thinking in terms of so maybe that that
helps out a bit alloy has to have a FAQ
for these ama's no I don't have thank
you for amazed I don't know where I
would put it alright let's see what
other people have got here a little gnat
flying around ever consider doing a core
concept series on heidegger's on the way
to language I'm a big fan of your
Heidegger videos I mean yeah I think if
I if I'm gonna do more Heidegger first
of all I do things for my classes right
and so what do I end up teaching you
know how do usually comes up when I'm
like teaching an existentialism class so
things like the you know what does
metaphysics make sense for me to do or
intro to being in time I'm going to do
other parts of being in time that that
fit in with that like about that you
know for before equi primordial x' i
need to get that stuff done for my
students but yeah there's there's other
other things I mean I would really like
to do some work on some of Heidegger's
lectures because there's a lot of cool
stuff in there but there's nothing to
keep me from doing others Laura awesome
Tony what do I think about Nietzsche
I think Nietzsche is a really important
philosopher well worth reading and
studying don't expect to understand
everything 1st or 30th time around he's
not ultimately going to be
what would be the word he's not not
everything's gonna fit together he's not
that kind of philosopher that doesn't
mean that it's not a coherent take but
it will be contradictory because nature
thinks that reality itself is
contradictory I think he's he's another
thing I can say is Nietzsche is
definitely somebody who you want to
study because he has some concepts that
are particularly helpful for for
understanding other things and and
sometimes they've been reappropriation
but other people have worked out further
great example is the notion of
resentiment
core idea of Nietzsche really brilliant
mock Schaller has a book called reason
to mock where he takes Nietzsche's work
a bit further than Nature himself did so
well worth checking out Michael Mason in
one of your earlier videos you mentioned
you like Spinoza I was wondering if you
can explain that a little bit it's not
that I don't like Spinoza and I just I'm
not that into Spinoza people are always
like yeah people that are into Spinoza
are really into Spinoza but I think that
probably I would bet 90% of the people
who talk about Spinoza haven't really
read much that knows that they've read
glosses on Spinoza because you know if
you actually read the ethics which is
probably his most important work that's
really tough going and I don't think
that most people who you know are
billing themselves as Spinoza fans have
really managed to get to get through it
I just you know I think that that
Spinoza is interesting but he's not as
important as people have made him out to
be there's a lot of other philosophers
who I just think are more interesting to
work on Alan says how do you see how
philosophy was practiced and how it is
now how philosophy is practiced now is
it's like a patchwork of lots and lots
and lots of different things
nobody can generalize about philosophy
and the present and not be
crap because there are so many different
things going on in so many different
projects like people are like well
there's basically two kinds of
philosophy analytic and continental
that's [ __ ]
you know there's classical American
there's history of philosophy which is
done in different ways there's
comparative philosophy
there's you know all sorts of other
things going on as well tradition
constituted rationality ala MacIntyre
Julie on us or people like that it's
it's impossible to really generalize
about it you could you could say well a
lot of english-speaking places and
Scandinavian places are in the analytic
philosophy but even analytic philosophy
is this huge patchwork of stuff that's
largely lost connections with its
historical roots and I don't mean
historical roots in the whole history of
philosophy I mean its historical roots
in people like Vic and Stein and Russel
and wisdom and you know early more
people like that Carnap right they're
they're not even all that that well read
by contemporary analytic philosophers so
all right peple I'm gonna probably
mangle this name set set ton off dr.
Stadler my son is 14 how would you
recommend I start him in philosophy well
I always say start with Plato platonic
dialogues read reads some of those with
him and and and talk about the issues
and you know talking about how they can
be read on multiple levels and different
takes and that's a great place to start
I mean there's plenty of other places to
you know a lot of people swear by give
them Sophie's world I'm in read Sophie's
world so I don't know if it's any good
it's not a lot of other people seem to
think it's really great I I suspect it's
probably the zen and the art of
motorcycle maintenance for this
generation or something but I don't know
you know I think there's probably many
many different ways you could start
somebody off with philosophy but
probably you want to introduce them to
original texts rather than you know
predigested somebody else's takes why I
read
what somebody else has to say about
Plato why not read some Plato or why
read what-what you know somebody else
has to say about Nietzsche why not read
some Nietzsche you know get get to the
source Arman have you read Heidegger's
compiled lectures on Parmenides I have
not so I've definitely not read my way
even through all of Heidegger's stuff on
Aristotle all right CMX
I mean canny is it necessary to be good
at math to study philosophy missus
snarky says I hope not no it's it's it's
not it depends on the type of philosophy
that you're doing even the stuff that's
very heavily on logical notation which
was kind of big and analytic philosophy
for quite a while you don't actually
need to know any math to do that because
it's it's all you know such low level
stuff that they're they're doing I mean
it's nice to know about mathematics if
somebody wants to make statements about
you know probability it's good to know
something about the theory of
probability right and some great
philosophers were also really important
mathematicians you might think for
example of live Nets who you know
invented along with Newton granted the
integral calculus or Descartes Cartesian
geometry Pascal theory of probability
lots of lots of cool people along the
way but I no I don't think it's
absolutely necessary and you know in
continental philosophy the uses that
people make of they derive from
mathematics or logic are usually they're
not related to actual mathematics
they're they're they're using them as
sort of symbols and doing what they want
with them so it's probably not going to
help you to know that much about it all
right
Matt Tucker what's your opinion on the
free will deter and debate I don't get
involved in debates because it's usually
[ __ ] and people like precipitate you
know this I versus this side almost
nothing ever dawn a family out of
and it depends on what you mean by free
will it's not a term that has one single
meaning I think that Free Will exists
but then you got is specify what you
mean if you mean like being you know
every single thing being able to make a
purely spontaneous decision at any time
clearly that's nonsense
but the notion that everything is
deterministic is also nonsense if you
think it through you know and what I
always find interesting are the accounts
that say how freedom and determinism
mesh in with each other you know I'm
very uninterested in classifying people
as libertarians compatibilist or
determinists I always want to know well
how is how does the the determining
factors how do they fit in with moments
of freedom and how can we increase
freedom that's the interesting thing how
can we lose freedom right all right
hardik Gupta your views on solipsistic
for years yes I just don't take it why
would I take it seriously right if I was
taking it seriously I would ignore all
the rest of you because you're all
figments of my imagination and I would
have nothing to say to you and you know
likewise
why would you want me to talk about it
you'd want me to say that you're the the
one single human existing in the center
of the universe that'd be ridiculous
so I don't really have use on solipsism
this is snarky my son read the
enchiridion it's a simple read short and
easy to comprehend yeah that's not a bad
place to start good you know Epictetus
is good to read you could start with all
sorts of things
I mean epic penis is kind of late right
there's lots of philosophy happening
before him but you know we can always
backtrack that you know that we don't
have to have like the one right place to
start things off that's the good thing
about philosophy it's an iterative
process no matter what you pick you
probably picked something that you're
going to have to go back to later on in
order to make sure that you understood
it
alright Dan another debate thing do you
have a side on the realism versus
anti-realism debate in the philosophy of
science or maybe you have some reading
recommendations I know I don't do
philosophy of science so I don't have a
dog in that that you know that fight so
to speak I I'm a realist I guess you
would say I think that that being said a
lot of things are social constructs I
don't know a lot of these debates I look
at them and I like wow you've really
picked a weird way to spend your career
arguing just about this versus this you
know especially the isms you know I'm
more interested in people actually
constructing accounts and and trying to
make some sense out of the world that we
live in and and have to you know somehow
fix or you know adapt ourselves to so
alright so M x24 a please is blundell a
kind of neoplatonist philosopher so it's
blown Dale not blundell I'm laughing
because blundell like he's blundering
around or something like that so Wayne
Hankey is the person who put forward the
idea that blown Della's and neoplatonist
but Wayne Hankey expands neoplatonist to
encompass so many things that are not
neoplatonism that the answer is no he's
not
interestingly you know blown del knew
the neoplatonist because he taught that
stuff when he was teaching as a
professor in his classes he's also one
of the people who introduced before Jill
Sohn did introduce medieval philosophy
to the curriculum in French philosophy
no Blondell is not a neoplatonist blown
Dallas a blown DeLeon he's doing his own
thing
the best thing you could probably read
in order to get a sense of blown Del's
early work which is most of what's been
translated although all of a
Shut has recently translated one of
blown dilator works that will be coming
out I don't remember which press but I
was invited I was invited to review it
over the summer but the early work is
you know like accion 1893 read through
it you'll see you know he's doing a
different sort of thing
he's he's not in a he's not in a ISM and
then read the letter on apologetics and
you'll see that he thinks that Christian
philosophy and you know modern
philosophy they have to somehow come to
terms with each other there can't be any
return you couldn't return to
Neoplatonism any any more than you could
to moribund scholasticism of the time
that he was he was working so now but
he's cool to read he's well worth
reading you might also check out fee
Accra long it's kind of pricey I think
because if I remember right it's one of
those Dutch presses like Kluwer that
published it but he's got some really
cool essays again from the early times
like on his concrete logic and stuff
like that so those are those are worth
checking out
whew toe toe step Nate can one jump into
shale errs formalism or will you need
certain text under your belt before yet
you can jump into any text you want at
any time and then you can discover that
you need certain texts under your belt
Schaller is good with giving you
references he's a pretty systematic guy
I mean it helps to have it really helps
to know something about Khan because
Schaller is reacting to him and you know
know something about classical virtue
ethics but I think you could read it but
before I would jump into that big thick
book I would you know I would read
another work by Schaller that's shorter
like his ressentiment book or his book
on sympathy or there's there's like
anthologies that have his collected
essays because you know formalism and
ethics is a huge book so I I would I
would if you're starting with Schaller I
wouldn't start necessarily with that
book
um alright
yes Derb whose translation of Plato
would you recommend I don't make
recommendations about translations I
don't really you know I'm lazy because I
can read the original and and I've been
reading for so many years that I don't
have too much trouble with it I give my
students public domain translations but
I cover the stuff in class as well I
don't stay on top of like who's
translating what you know and I say that
in my I said it over and over again and
EMA's and I say that as well in like my
how to study Plato video you know giving
advice about that that I'm just not a
particularly qualified person I can tell
you this I'm pretty forgiving to
translations but because I've done a lot
of translating work myself
let's see Mohammed says what do you
think sam Harris appears at 12 among
spiritually influential people
what's my current take on metaphysics
and religion so yeah I'm sure Sam Harris
is on a big list cuz he sells lots of
books and he's got some you know fairly
simplistic stuff that he consistently
says to people over and over again he's
a celebrity right
I'd say he's not a great intellectual
and I would say that a hundred years
from now nobody's gonna be talking about
that guy except for you know a few
scholars that are like this is this
branch of popular blah blah blah was
doing this at the time um but there's
you know tons of people out there like
him I don't really pay much attention to
them because they go they come and go
from decade to decade I don't think he's
making any lasting contribution to the
field no of course you know maybe I'm
not either
oh but at least I I seem to you know
seem to know what I'm talking about
and I'll say - I haven't read a lot of
his stuff and I don't I don't watch his
videos because the bit that I've looked
at didn't impress me life is short
you only got so much time to do things
but it's understandable that people like
that that that sort of thing you know
maybe hopefully they move on from it
from Harrison to better stuff Alex what
do you think about curl it Carl young
and do you think that objective
philosophical truths can be found by
studying Universal ideas across
Agriculture's well I'll start with the
second part can we find objective
philosophical truth depends on what you
mean by objective by studying universal
ideas across every culture you're not
going to find many things that are in
every single culture but you can find a
lot that you know is common to many
cultures and you know the truth doesn't
have to necessarily be found in every
single culture in order to be worthwhile
as a matter of fact that's that's how we
grow as a species is people discover
something over here and then it gets
transferred over here and reinterpreted
you know so that that's cool what I
think about young I mean I like reading
him he's got a good style I don't buy
into any of his ideas really I think
he's more interesting when he's not
expounding his own ideas but talking
about other people I think then many
displays more insight and I have rarely
come away from a conversation with a
union meaning somebody who's like
devoted to you where I didn't think that
I had wasted my time but maybe that's a
factor of of that of the kind of people
that are really into young so you know
not a huge fan when it comes to
psychoanalysts I'm much more interested
in somebody like Lacan but even the kind
I think half of the stuff he does is
[ __ ] you know so we strip away the
[ __ ] and find some other interesting
stuff or Hans cohort or you know these
Charles Winnicott and people like that
you know I'm very pragmatic when it
comes to psychotherapeutic concepts I
want to see stuff that can can work I'm
not looking for a vast system that
explains everything
and I'm not a big person into you know
like mysticism or that sort of thing
myself so that I don't have much of a
bent towards that uh Greg Greg Greg I'll
special what's your opinion on the
Frankfurt School especially their
relationship to Hegel well they have a
relationship to Hegel they all make what
they want out of Hegel and the Frankfurt
School so who are we talking about you
know people like my Horkheimer Theodor
Adorno
you know Mark who'sa from people like
that and then later on you know people
like hopper Maus I think there are
they're worth reading they're worth
thinking about I wouldn't say that I
wouldn't say there's a consistent take
among them I think their project was
really interesting trying to figure out
you know what with the original origin
of the frankfurt school world war one
happened and the proletariat according
to a sort of standard marxist theory
should have risen up and fought against
the the bourgeoisie who was sending them
off to war and instead they went off to
war and fought and nationalism really
trumped class consciousness
so the frankfurt school were like what
the hell happened here right that's when
they started getting into all of their
studies and they picked a good time to
do it now you know with somebody like
Habermas it's it's a very different sort
of project but i think they're worth
reading Adorno is very hard to write on
because his work is so incredibly rich
and there is no system there Horkheimer
is quite a bit easier I'd say so is Mark
who's a Erich Fromm very easy I'm
leaving some some peat somebody out but
I can't remember who all right Amin says
the British steel shirt is dope yeah
it's got the my nice big hand on it I
bought this at a Judas Priest concert
years and years and years ago
Kyle asks do I think the self is a
substance like any other or is the self
really appear nothingness I don't think
it's either
I think the self is a rather you know
unique substance because it's self
referential this coffee cup doesn't have
any opinions on it self myself does and
I do I do believe that there is
something like a substantial self but I
don't think it's like some single node I
think it's more like a big network that
has continuity within it so I'm you know
I'm more attracted to views like that of
the Stoics you know
Aristotle can be tweaked that way I
think as well I don't believe in
something like a platonic conception of
the soul
this is like these ghosts that kind of
Flitz away or something like that so and
they're there any there's large parts of
the self that the self thinks are
substantial that are actually grounded
on nothingness but so does an some right
just read some of his later treatises
and you'll talk about you know the lack
the privation within us which is an idea
coming from Augustine by the way so
there's plenty of room for that sort of
thing in traditional philosophy hoops
thing just jumped a lot of people have
been asking questions let's see if I can
scroll back up to where I was all right
here we go
[Music]
Singh Goths I think it is what are the
primary philosophical implications of
hyper-intelligent extraterrestrial or
extra-dimensional life was discovered in
the 21st century oh yeah yeah so I think
that would bring about pretty you know
they bring about some some interesting
crises for a lot of us many human beings
would be very bothered by the notion of
there being something higher
up on the intellectual food chain than
us the implication would be that we we
could maybe get some information from we
can actually ask them some of the tough
questions and I would expect that we
would find that quite a few that would
be like I don't know well we've been
puzzling about this stuff for a long
time and we haven't achieved consensus
either but here's though here's our our
best stabs at it and maybe they'd be
less violent than us and they'd be less
willing to commit to stupid ideologies
and you know less wasteful of resources
and and maybe their politics would
actually work so they don't destroy
their own environment or you know waste
pretty much most of their resources on
competition with each other so you know
we can learn something from from them
hopefully right that would be kind of
nice but I think it would also it would
produce like you know all sorts of crazy
reactions or people these are Devils you
know wipe them out
so all right Marty Fitzgerald hey dr.
Sadler we had some time ago at ACPA when
I was still an undergrad just wanted to
drop by to say I finished my masters and
started a joint PhD and bioethics and
philosophy good job yeah that's that's a
nice set of fields to be working in it's
been a it must have been some time ago
at an ACPA because I think the last one
I was at was was it in Boston maybe and
I was still living out in New York
usually I only go if I'm presenting a
paper or if it's nearby so as a matter
of fact that's that's really the case
with all conferences these days because
I'm so busy so all right Alex mayor
Meyer how to stay motivated through a
long and difficult philosophical tax
struggling with a critique of pure peace
okay yeah that is a long and difficult
one I suppose you could remind yourself
of like the payoff at the end and I'm
gonna understand how all these things
fit in together which which is true with
can't at least but yeah you know maybe
you take a break and then you come back
to and take a break and come back to it
it's an iterative process you could
commiserate with other people you can
also remind yourself that some of Kant's
works are more fun to read you know when
it comes to critiques the third critique
is wild and crazy the second critique is
very straightforward and a lot of fun
first critique it is kind of a chore so
yeah all right Matt on a scale from one
to ten how big of a toll most would I
consider myself to be I know I'm a
follower of Anselm primarily I'm not a
follower of Anselm primarily but do you
accept Thomas's or Aquinas is philosophy
of the five ways I mean I'm an eclectic
so I draw upon a lot of people it's kind
of funny because I've done enough like
studying in quite a few things where I
probably in some cases know more and
accept more from a given philosopher or
tradition than the people who
self-identify with that tradition but a
lot of stuff I like in Thomas you know I
drop pretty heavily when I'm talking
about anger management I draw on his
theory of anger I'm not prying I don't
worry about arguments for God's
existence I teach them in class but you
know my own conduct is not based on
having a I'm not an apologetic sist
you know Anselm's argument by the way is
not the ontological argument contained
in pro slogan too it's the entire the
argument that Wyndham argumentum is pro
so Jian won all the way through the
whole thing except for the last three
chapters which are cognac Tony's so you
know and I I think Thomas is important
I've translated his works you know the
commentary on the Psalms and assisted in
proofreading other commentaries but
Thomas is one among many and I don't
think it's important to be at ulmus
any more than it's important to be an
Anselm Ian you know or a Hobbesian or a
Descartes in a Cartesian or something
like that I think that we you know where
we can be intelligent eclectic and draw
upon many of the the things I'm Kyle
what's my thoughts on a thousand Plateau
it's been so long since I've read it I'm
not I'll tell you this I find the stuff
that Deleuze writes with guitar e less
interesting than the stuff he writes on
his own so the logic of sense really
like write essays critical in clinical I
really like his history is a philosophy
stuff I really like anti Oedipus not so
much but it's been a long time since
I've looked at thousand plateaus mr.
white can you recommend a practical
school of philosophy for persons with
cognitive or behavioral difficulties it
depends on what your cognitive or
behavioral difficulties are I suppose I
mean I think that it's great to study
stoicism that's why I although I don't
self-identify you know as an orthodox
stoic I'm the editor of stoicism today
and organizing a stoic on here because
and I'm also teaching it in my classes
particularly in my philosophy
mindfulness and life class and teaching
this semester so that's you know that
might be a place to start
ZT good question here who are the most
underrated or neglected philosophers in
your opinion well you know in the
present Maurice Blondell was one of them
it's one of the reasons why I wrote my
dissertation on him I really like left
chest off the Russian Jewish
existentialist author
I think his works are you know really
neglected there's very few people who
read him but he's really great he's a
very anti systematic who else comes to
mind of hand
I mean Cicero I was just talking about
that in my write for he still gets
tagged as being oh he's not original
it's only in the 19th century that we
know so my connection is unstable what's
going on here there we go
it's only in the 19th century that we
get this kind of crazy you know only
Plato and Aristotle mattered all the
Hellenistic philosophers are garbage as
a matter of fact somebody else who I
think is underrated whose other
Hellenistic from opera Plutarch people
know him for his his biographies but
they don't realize that he wrote just as
much work I think in terms of you know
straight out philosophy and he's a
really important source for
understanding what's going on not just
in his own middle Platonism but also in
the Aristotelian ISM of
well where the hell is she she very
important and she gets left out quiet
quite a lot there's other women authors
to that that are in quite interesting
that should probably get more place but
I don't do as much work on them one who
is you know really important in the 20th
century and hasn't she's getting a read
now or at least people are buying her
books now since the Trump era and she's
got a book called the origins of
totalitarianism tan Arendt I'm convinced
that almost anybody who talks about the
origins of totalitarianism probably
hasn't read the book because it's
incredibly dense you know and a long way
to go through it and a lot of people
like to buy books just to talk about
them similar thing by the way I'll say
with anti Oedipus lots of people posting
about anti Oedipus I think most of the
people have post about it haven't
actually read the book but you know so
those are some underrated philosophers
[Music]
Cohen Davis have I ever done a class on
Eastern philosophy yeah and my first
teaching position I had to teach the
entire curriculum not only for lost
delicious studies that was my prison
teaching job huh we got an unstable
cushion again I taught some you know I
teach some stuff world religions class
but that was at sort of a low level you
know really basic stuff and then I did
get to teach eventually a Eastern
religions and philosophy class and so we
looked at you know Indian traditions we
looked at Chinese tradition that was
about as far as we got
but it's not it's not an area of
specialization Kyle I'm kind of
interested in monism but I've heard so
many people caution against the thoughts
I read what you're interested in you
don't you don't have to buy into
something just because you read about it
see what you think about monism there's
a lot of different monism Zout there too
so Jakob says for an existentialist or
konchem do we always have radical
freedom or only when we were
adults good question
I don't know what contactually says
about that I mean you know somebody who
does talk about that is Simone de
Beauvoir in the ethics of ambiguity and
she says that children don't have
freedom in the way that adults do and
that one of the problems with a lot of
people is that they're kept in a
childlike condition so that they they're
never really able to exercise genuine
freedom and that part of what we ought
to be doing part of our moral imperative
is to make it possible for them to enjoy
freedom so yeah Jack what do I think
about dairy does of spirit been so long
since I read it you know I went through
a Dairy deaf phase when I was in
graduate school and read most of the
stuff that he had available at the time
I don't really remember much about it
Jonathan
no gusto for Hegel is the dialectic a
method or a result I don't think it's
really either you know dialectic is what
it is and it's how things develop out of
themselves or you can turn it into a
method if you want but then you're kind
of doing cookie cutter Hegel all right
we got the you know the thesis then we
got the antithesis then we get the
synthesis coming out of it that's the
Hegel 3 step no not exactly
I mean if you read through the
phenomenology you see that the word
antithesis comes up over and over again
without necessarily being connected with
a new synthesis or things like that all
right
Mohamad Oh Cohen says anything on an R
and I've done stuff on R and I I talk
about her when I do an ethics class I
actually I need to do some core concept
videos for the online ethics classes
that I do on her virtuous selfishness
which is usually the text that I teach I
think you know I think she's a
philosopher unlike a lot of my academic
colleagues I also think that she's a at
best third-rate philosopher who's a
terrible historian of philosophy but you
know she's she's interesting so I you
know I'm not impressed with her fans but
yeah mohamad reading a paper God in the
death of Islam Muhammad Iqbal 'z
reception of Friedrich Nietzsche was a
bit shocking I'll have to take your word
for it I've never read it ball so you
know sound sounds it sounds interesting
but all right Irv can you list which
philosophers have followers or a
following like Spinoza why does this
occur in some philosophers and not
others there's also I don't know I can i
list who's got followings there's
literally like thousands of philosophers
you could say with followings I don't
let Spinoza is the biggest following
either and you know we also have to I
suppose we have to distinguish like
serious committed have read the works
kind of followers from fanboy fangirl
philosopher or followers who are like
I've heard about this thing and sounds
really cool
I think Toulouse is a lot of followers
like that - so does Bertrand Russell by
the way and so does that Iran right but
what what determines whether one person
has followers or not a lot of it is
historical circumstances that are beyond
their control sometimes you know they
it's because they made a genuine effort
to become famous there's a great article
out there about you know somebody else
who's gonna be totally forgotten 100
years from now Jordan Peterson and about
you know the steps that he took
basically to try to make himself a
celebrity so yeah all right Muhammad
says can I say anything on paul tillich
or christian existential ism yeah read
gabrielle Marcel he's a great Christian
existentialist till like I don't read
much you know I I always found him kind
of superficial we had to read him he was
quite popular when I was an
undergraduate
you know the courage to be and stuff
like that I just I never found him that
interesting but there's so there's
another great Christian existentialist
out there that are that are worth
reading nakusha do I think contemporary
philosophers aren't brave or radical
enough know which contemporary
philosophers do we mean I mean again I
said this at the beginning it's very
hard to generalize about all
philosophers at this time I think
there's a lot of people who have
academic positions that are you know
they're not particularly brave but what
are they supposed to be doing are they
supposed to be like out there on the
streets preaching philosophy or you know
a lot of times people are brave it turns
out to be just you know they're they're
really conformists and and they're
embracing a fad or they they're going
down some rabbit hole and finding crap
at the bottom right so I don't know
you know I the people that I
particularly like I think they're quite
brave enough you know Alastair MacIntyre
is a prime example you know Julianna's a
lot of these people are like historian
of philosophy people though so woolen
what do I think of de luces ontology I
don't know that I actually know enough
of what what Deleuze actually thinks
ontology is to say anything
Bruno I've heard you say there is no
science with a capital S only sciences
what are some of the differences in
similarity between philosophy and the
sciences depends on what kind of
philosophy you're talking about there is
no capital P single thing philosophy any
more than there are you know just the
capital s all science right so it
depends on what you're talking about end
results haven't read any sterner the
forerunner of nature or anything on
egoism yeah I've read I've read through
the ego and its own I've actually toyed
with the idea of shooting some core
concept videos on him he's an
interesting sort of well we call him
cul-de-sac right I don't thinks Turner
is really that influential on Nietzsche
there they're doing similar things but I
think if you want to like show a genetic
influence that that's kind of tough I
think Nietzsche is Nietzsche and I will
say this sterner is egoism is definitely
radical it's I mean you put like sterner
up against Iran you know who's this
devotee of capitalism strand I would say
well that's all [ __ ] too you know
spooks was what he'd call it right
Turner's in some respect more consistent
and and I like reading him he's
interesting he does actually use he is a
Hegelian he does like the you know I
mentioned the the 3-step thing is not
actually Hagel himself but Haig aliens
did did kind of use that and in in his
like account there are a lot of triads
aren't there so he's fun III should
actually put together materials on him
for my my ethics class when I do the
egoism stuff I just haven't gotten
around to it there's so many projects I
have that I I never get to Oh Bal Khan
if you have an advice to the younger you
what might this advice be so that I
could do like a whole video on that
professionally I probably would have
given I could have given my younger self
the advice to go to a school with a
higher ranking and I won't say a better
school because Southern Illinois
University at the time that I was there
for me it was an amazing place
they had a great research library pretty
much the equal of Notre Dame's Hesburgh
library I would say which is unusual for
a not that well funded state school but
they had a just amazing research library
I had some pretty good professors there
some of them outside of the philosophy
department you know some in the classics
department some of the English some of
the speech comm and I caught them at the
right time when they were you know able
to really devote themselves to teaching
well in some cases before they left or
retired or got sidelined and and it was
it was a good climate but as far as
career choices go it was not a good
career choice because whether you get
hired or not depends on where you went
that's pedigree where you're currently
working who you know who your contacts
are and what you've published it's
academics is not a meritocracy and the
people at the top are usually I
discovered this to interact them not a
lot better and sometimes actually quite
worse than the rest of us so I probably
would have given myself saw advice like
that there's a lot of stuff where I
really sweated the small stuff where I
would say don't don't worry about that
also too I would I started so many like
this is gonna be a book you know that
I'm gonna do so many projects where I
could have said to myself now you're
never going to do that maybe spend your
time on something else right and another
piece of advice I would have given
myself
is never stopped exercising never let
yourself get out of shape I used to be
what people would call a fitness nut
right except it wasn't about fitness it
was about having a good-looking body and
being very strong and you know I used to
do like you suspend about on average
five days a week sometimes six days a
week three hours a day exercising in one
way or another whether it was endurance
lifting or piling a bunch of weights in
my my backpack like 70 pounds and going
for a five-mile hike or you know biking
everywhere you know things like that
right and then I get to the point where
I just got there was no longer
interested in it and I found it boring
and I let myself get out of shape it's
so much harder to get and I've had I've
had periods where I get myself back in
shape and then I you know things that
usually I get too busy and then I'd get
out of shape now I'm in one of those
getting back and shaped things again and
I've lost you know like 20 pounds in the
last two months I'm lifting more than I
have in years I wait you know I ideally
I'd be able to go to the the gym more
often right now it's three days a week
but I walk five miles some of the other
days but it's so much harder to get your
body back in the condition in your late
40s than it is in your 20s so I'm gonna
tell myself never ever ever let yourself
get out of shape and you know and there
probably be some other things along as
well all right
Watergate 2.0 what do I think about show
up an hour I believe his ethics are
great even though they're not original
oh I'd say how is pretty original
I like show up an hour he's a really
good writer he's very interesting I
haven't had the chance to teach him very
often I did actually have the
opportunity when my my wife was studying
at European Graduate School which is in
South Face Switzerland and I I went over
there they made me a was like visiting
researcher or something like that they
gave me some title and that that let me
take a class with them and so you know
Wolfgang Schirrmacher at that time was
the president of EGS and he was teaching
a class on Schopenhauer and he is been
like the president of the International
Schopenhauer in society and written
books on Schopenhauer so I'm like I'm
taking class that guy you know not these
other people and it was really quite
good there's a two-week very intensive
thing opportunity to read the text
deeply again really enjoy it at
beautiful setting - by the way sauce
face with someone in summer I winter I
don't if you like skiing it's cool but I
don't think I'd want to be there in
winter so yeah I really like
Schopenhauer he's just one of these
people I don't get to unfortunately all
that often
Alejandro Haydock say other big thing
and there haven't got much time for
YouTube since I'm studying two careers
and have a job that's still trying to
keep off the channel still loving what I
do thanks that's very very nice all
right Adam Riga your videos help me with
my bachelor's and philosophy cheers well
again thanks it's that's nice
Mohammed can I please start detailed
book reviews kindly ask your audience if
they would like it I'd like to do it too
it's just a matter of having the time
like I was saying earlier and you know
teaching seven classes this semester do
you know if the average load at a
teaching colleges for you know it isn't
like a place like you know research
university one or two so I'm teaching a
huge amount of classes with a lot of
students and have a business and do
speaking and go on and on and on so I'm
not I'm not not getting to it because
I'm not interested in it I'm not getting
to it because there's only so many hours
in each day all right all right
alejandra asks it whether i'm familiar
with the losses Nietzsche interpretation
yeah Nietzsche is about force right
that's the primary concept into losses
Nietzsche book when it when I took my
graduate level
Nietzsche class with Stephen Timon the
second week of class I was presenting to
lose his book on Nietzsche and I think
you know I think he's Deleuze is always
interesting he has especially when he's
doing history philosophy he's always got
some good insights you always got to be
careful that you're not getting more to
lose than the figure that he's talking
about but that's okay because the lose
is is interesting danzón says where did
the trichotomy of control come from is
referring to stoicism I thought there's
only things in our control and outside
of our control how can there possibly be
a third option well that's coming from
William Irvine he's the one who came up
with the trichotomy of control so you're
gonna want to read his book about the
stoicism and then you can decide for
yourself or you can read summaries of it
online I have an article actually on
Epictetus and what in our control and
out not in our control actually means
over at the partially examined life and
that would give you some idea of what's
what's going on there let's see what
else we got Muhammad and how do I see
the relationship between literature and
philosophy I don't see it as a strong
dividing line there's some great
philosophy that's done through
literature again you know I mentioned
somebody like philip k dick he has
characters talking philosophy in his
various novels and it's always an
interesting take that they have you can
take philosophical themes and present
them through the the medium of
literature somebody else was really good
at that Dostoevsky is characters you
know either represent philosophical
concepts and ways of life or they talk
philosophy sometimes getting it right
sometimes getting it wrong so I I think
that there's a lot of overlap between
and philosophy and you know quite
frankly I would add that if somebody
tries to say that you know literature
there's no philosophical stuff to it
that that would be like one sign to me
that I should just like not listen to
that person and you know not give them
my time which which is something that I
have a choice about right
Watergate asks who's the first
philosopher ever to be known I don't
know I mean Diogenes layer taste is
doing sort of a reconstructive project
and he's saying that you know these
ancient religious people are
philosophers but it it really depends on
what you call Philosopher's right so I
guess the always is usually in the West
the person that we say is the first
philosopher Michael Mason is asking
another sterner question you ever read
on moxtra nor much now I really say go
I've read mocks Turner and I can see how
he relates to Hegel because it's quite
it's right there in the text so yeah
[Music]
let's see here
marcos corona which whose theory of
justice do you find most interesting I
mean if I had to pick an Psalms because
justice is an architectonic virtue for
him but he doesn't actually have a full
like theory you know like a book called
the theory of justice or anything
Adam thoughts on sexist empirica swooz
recommended him by a friend who loves
loving us and it knows how much I like
the classics well I will say this I
don't see any connection whatsoever
between loving us and sexist empirical
sexist is a later skeptic writer the
skeptics were one of the five main
schools of philosophy in the Hellenistic
era well worth reading
we actually he's one of these people
like Cicero or Plutarch or even
Aristotle to some degree that are
important in part because we we know
about other authors because
quotations by like sexist empirical the
Stoics say XYZ and here's why they're
wrong
well that stoic say XYZ it's nice for us
to have that right and he's an
interesting writer so while we're
reading ahmad as a sci-fi question I
have just one question dune or
foundation I definitely do you know
foundation is good but it's not great
and as a matter of fact as a series the
fourth and fifth book the fifth book is
just awful and the fourth book is kind
of weak to now dune the the single one
volume of dune I would say has more
going on in it than all of the
Foundation series does and shows greater
breadth of thought than all of that and
then you add in you know the other
follow-up books and I'm not talking
about like his his kids you know
money-making ventures writing more and
more doing stuff later on I'm just
talking about Frank Herbert himself did
amazing it's amazing work so yeah
let's see some back-and-forth here
Philip would you say that st. Anselm
makes any major errors in his pro slogan
as a matter of fact I wouldn't I would I
would actually I mean the pro slogan is
an amazing work especially if you can
read it laughs it was like you know
watch I remember really reading it for
the first time when I was handling stuff
from my mom's funeral here in in the
Milwaukee area actually in one of the
suburbs not far from here Brookfield and
like sitting in a church in Elm Grove
I'm reading through the one that has a
facing English and and Latin
charlesworth his translations not
particularly good Williams is better as
a matter of fact almost everyone's
better
charlesworth or Dean Dean is also
misleading translator and just being am
i reading the Latin and being like holy
crap all of these you know argument the
all these sub arguments are part of this
large unum argumentum so there's no
errors you you kind of wish you would
have expanded on things
Artie would be played on Aristotle or
the Fathers of philosophy but could they
also be called the fathers of theology
no they're not theologians and I mean
there's you could say there's a little
bit of theology in a different sense
than we nowadays use theology in the two
but there's not much and I don't even
know that we want to call fathers of
philosophy they were important
philosophers but they weren't the only
game in town you know all right Matt
Tucker any general direction you head
towards in terms of a political
philosophies I lean towards anarchism
but just curious I'm a virtue ethicist
so I mean then that's not totally
incompatible with certain kinds of
anarchism by the way but it means that
like Aristotle I'm gonna look at as he
does in the politics look at all the
existing current regimes and say well
they're all screwed up it's a question
of how screwed up they are and where I'm
going to place my my commitments the
presidents to try to make things less
screwed up I think a lot of people
looking at my current commitments would
say that I'm somewhere on the left but
I'm also in some respects you know quite
conservative even traditional about
about the culture it's just that a lot
of the things that present-day people
who call themselves traditionalists and
conservatives get really upset about are
quite stupid and not worth saving you
know I'm in a gala terian I you know
when it comes to you know like say male
film female relations I think that you
know women should be able to like Plato
women should be able to do
the same things as men without getting
harassed for it or having to meet
different standards you know and we can
go on and on and on I'll say this when
it comes to political parties I'll be
voting Democrat in the current election
for a couple big reasons one is this
this current Republican administration
represents the worst of the worst of
what the Republicans had to offer and
the fact that the current Republicans
are too gutless to actually stand up to
this guy Trump and his his coterie is
just a sign of how corrupt they are and
how worthless they have and I'll say
this in Wisconsin here the Republicans
have shown themselves to be the party
that cares zero about the common good
and tries to screw things up as much as
possible when it comes to the
legislative process and so they're gonna
get punished by people like me who are
not joining the Democrat Party I'm a
registered independent but I'm sure as
hell you know it's one of those voting
for the the least of the evils right the
Republicans are definitely the bad guys
right now and if they want that to
change they need
come easiest moments and really
leadership and got their party start
over and you know there'd be no place
for them to do that then right here in
Wisconsin where the original Republican
Party was an anti-racist party a party
that fought for the common good things
that a virtue ethicists could get behind
so there's there's my political
commitments Mohamed lots of gonorrhea
Derrick's own interesting guy I like I
like
birdsong quite a bit I did an
independent study even on him that I
never actually got a grade for my mentor
back in grad school where we were going
over the it's called it's translated as
time in free will but it really should
be translated as the essay on the
immediate Gibbons of consciousness great
book Eric stone is a really interesting
thinker very important for revitalizing
metaphysics between him and blown-down
who's a little bit earlier and Marcel a
little bit later they're the ones who
really paved the way for phenomenology
to come into france as christian dupont
in his dissertation demonstrated years
ago so yeah important guy john man
thoughts on orthodox theology and the
transcendental argument je dire makes a
great argument for it also
recommendations for books on non
monotheistic theology I don't know what
Orthodox theology has to do with the
transcendental argument I don't know
what the transcendental argument is
supposed to be and I don't I don't
really you know I used to follow Dyer on
Twitter but I found his post interesting
so I don't know these up too so I really
have nothing to say about that barebone
oh I'd be interested in studying
philosophy well sounds like you answered
your own question you know get yourself
interested in it you know either you're
interested or you're not
what I don't know what I would say to
get you interested in it
you you think there's anything
interesting about it being David Dimmock
seventh and seven is argument against
the coherence of theism classical theism
I don't even know what that means that
sounds like some sort of you know
project and analytic philosophy of
religion so I don't even know what
that's asking Carl Jung has asked a
little bit earlier but ice age
technology as their philosophy their
yeah there's philosophy they're young
studied philosophy because he was part
of the literate culture of his time
tried studied philosophy too but you
know it's it's not I wouldn't say it's
particularly great philosophy Dylan
Morrison are you familiar with the works
of PD Pettis penske I am NOT and then
václav asked you know check philosopher
Yan Patoka only from the references to
him by dairy dies and not somebody I've
ever read poly a chromatic wave any
thoughts on Dugan having read him so I
know you know from from people asking
about him what he stands for but I
haven't actually read him maybe I will
eventually in the future if I can find
some time Moises Castellanos what do I
think about Heidegger's deconstruction
of philosophical language do I believe
it was fruitful or self-indulgent so
dari dad did deconstruction Heidegger
did destruction and if you're asking
about Derrida I think that dario DAWs
work falls in three main periods there's
the early period that includes speech
and phenomena on granite ology writing
and different stuff like that where he's
doing very careful interesting work and
then he became famous and he started
doing what I think to be kind of sloppy
playing around you know I'm the big guy
I get to do whatever I want work in the
middle period and I think most of that
is garbage and then he got interested in
issues of philosophy and politics and
later on and writes things like you know
operas inspectors of marks and and the
gift of death and I think that stuff is
pretty good but could have used some
some better editing because it's mostly
talks that he gives and they're like
this guy's so important let's just like
put this right out here could have used
some some editing work so that's my take
on Derrida Heidegger I think is very
important to study you know I was
actually working with a client this
morning on a thesis on Heidegger so yeah
David Piell who's making a significant
contribution to philosophy nowadays
tough for me to say about most fields I
can say that you know when it comes to
like the stuff I'm interested in you
know Christopher Gill has a new book out
you know McIntyre is still working away
you know Julia honest is still you know
churning away at stuff margaret graver
kind of a rising star in classical
philosophy i'd keep keep an eye on her
whatever she's doing it usually turns
out to be really quite quite great stuff
i mean who else is coming to my john
sellers is a new book out on stoicism
but i haven't taken a look at yet cuz
hasn't been sent to me but i'm hoping to
get a copy yeah so i know more about
what's going on in it taking classical
philosophy and adapting it to the the
present then about you know cool
cutting-edge stuff John oh you're get
finally get it from one what about G
Jack what about him you know sometimes
interesting big investment to try to
figure out what the hell he's saying a
lot of the time and then you know it may
or may not pay off I don't think that
he's gonna like you know like not not
for now for the same reason I think he's
a big
now I don't think that a hundred years
you know people are really gonna be
reading in much but it could be wrong
you know I'm pretty sure nobody's gonna
be reading me a hundred years arborist
to know us what is my take on climate
change both the philosophy of the
science behind and the ethical
implications climate change exists all
we got to do is actually like look
outside you know it's happened here in
Wisconsin we are now in a different zone
as far as like growing things species
haven't made it because you know the way
the way things have changed I here's
mine minded so oh there's there's human
caused climate change there's cyclical
climate change clearly cyclical climate
change has existed nobody's debating
that because anybody who says there's
never been any climate changes in that
ball human-caused climate change that
exists - it's pretty well demonstrated I
don't buy the like you know
well there's alternate viewpoints on
this sort of thing no it's pretty well
decided it's just a question of how much
and what we can do about it and I mean
is is sort of a sociological proof of
this the major institutions in in our
society if they didn't think that it was
real they wouldn't be investing so much
of their time and money into figuring
out you know what we're gonna do when
things get really screwed up and I don't
just mean the US military that years ago
already started doing planning for what
we're gonna do when the world goes crazy
because the you know the vast areas are
on the equator where a lot of people
live and dire poverty are gonna get
worse and worse that's going to
destabilize things
I mean corporations that own real estate
that are wondering about you know what's
the value of their real estate going to
be 20 years from now as sea levels rise
right climate changes is is happening
the question is is it going to kill us
as a species or just generate massive
misery or whether we're going to do
something about it and unfortunately
here in the United States we have two
main political parties one of which the
Republicans when it comes to climate
change are nutballs and they have
histologically no ground to stand up
it's pure you know prejudice and wishful
thinking and in some cases just shot in
front on their part that keeps them
denying it right and so that's that's
that's sheer stupidity the Democrats
show themselves almost you know the
establishment of the Democrats show
themselves ineffectual when it comes to
doing anything about it so we've got one
party that's clearly in this respect you
know
collaborating with with something that's
going to impose massive
other that's like you know maybe we can
make it a little bit money pushing along
I'll also add to that around the world
it wasn't all the conservative parties
that were saying no global warming isn't
happening
it was mostly ours and now we've managed
to export that to all these other groups
and now they're just as nutty as our
Conservatives are so it's one of those
things where we're all along for the
ride
what's going to happen I don't know I
just hope that we're able to like come
together on the common good and start
doing some things that are gonna start
fixing things and then maybe some of the
other countries in the world that have
you know more of a stake in their own
development might also say well the
Americans finally got their act together
let's get behind it as well but it may
be it may be too late and this would be
a case where we're unable to come to a
political solution to what is a
technological problem the the
technological you know solves our there
it's it's it's a matter of actually
being able to work out our crazy
[ __ ] and maybe we can't so a Jag
we're really helpful how do you see
present condition of philosophy as many
people tend not to come this way
academically from a student of
philosophy well there's you know there's
academic philosophy that's doing what it
does right a lot of which is pretty you
know removed from ordinary people it has
almost nothing to say to them and I
think a lot of the academics love it
that way you know they're like being in
their little club and then there's
there's like the poseur public
philosophy people who basically try to
control the discourse and then there's
the people like us who actually do
public philosophy right who are who are
the doers rather than the controller's
or the poopoo right and I think that's
that's pretty much it
um all right between the III maybe
between Hamas and Adorno there's a big
gap yeah that's true
you mean Hamas and and see that because
he talks about that Jake love my beard
somebody posted recently that it was
like one part like sage in one part you
know metal head and my answer was the
secret ingredient is laziness
it just happens to grow this way it
doesn't grow up here except in little
batches you know and so that that's how
it turns out and I'm too lazy to trim it
or to to cut it so that's that's what I
have
Jakob asked to address the question on
existentialist and caching for you and I
already did that Anglo Eber match what
is your advice to an 18 year old
Nietzschean Nietzschean before
university hmm yeah don't go around
telling people you're in Nietzschean
because the ones who don't know what
you're talking about are gonna be like
what the hell is that and then a lot of
other people are gonna be like oh I'm
gonna stay away from that person cuz
Nietzsche is you know kind of a jerk
right
[Music]
the real nations would conceal their
Nietzschean ISM a phantom upload how did
you handle anger in the military not
well I mean at one point I told my squad
leader that I was hoping that you know
we would we would get to go out you know
that we'd go to war so that we could we
could frag him and the rest of the squad
was cool with that too because we used
to call him the Grinch who stole the gis
Christmas it was such an awful guy I
didn't I didn't handle anger well in the
military I was I was like you know 18 19
years old so alright I'm I've got a
couple minutes left so I'm gonna skip
around a little bit and see some some
stuff that I could answer fairly quickly
so I'm gonna scroll down let's see what
we got here
a lot of questions here
here's a good one Brenda found onsen I'm
a senior my local university the
University of Minnesota is a program to
allow seniors to take courses it's been
forever since 1975 where should I start
well if you're talking about philosophy
taking intro to philosophy or an ethics
class those are the real beginner level
things don't expect it necessarily to be
the you know the best because it's it's
totally up to whoever they they assign
you and so they they might be good or
they they might not be let's see what
else we got here doo doo doo doo doo
late-stage I read in Malcolm X's
autobiography thought Schopenhauer Hegel
and Nietzsche influenced Hitler do you
think that was the case I mean I haven't
read mine Kampf other than little
selections from it but I think he's kind
of doing his own thing
Hitler by the way drew a lot on American
racists he thought that that you know
American largely anti black racists and
really managed to up the game compared
to put people in Europe and so he you
know he drew a lot upon our homegrown
strains of racism Hitler wasn't a
philosopher you know so I wouldn't worry
about that people are always trying to
trace things back to Nietzsche or Hegel
or whoever those are usually a real
stretch to do to do ah here's an
interesting one from Matt Tucker
speaking of Diogenes how do you feel
about the one from sigh nope so
Epictetus
actually has a really great chapter in
the discourses on the calling of the
cynic philosopher he's not mentioning
Diogenes accepted a couple points by
name but the cynics were the Stoics
looked at the cynics as being sort of
like the hardcore
taking the shortcut to virtue but also
kind of full of themselves on occasion
illusion of Sam soda by the way skewers
the cynics for being just a bunch of
humbugs who like you know talk the good
talk about being a cynic but don't
actually live up to it so you know I
would actually read what epictetus has
to say about about them so that's good
well here's a stupid comment from Anglo
over munch oh no he's left-wing someone
passed this man an economics book boy
right-wingers think that like oh you're
just you don't know what an
understeering economics such a stupid
stupid conference hopefully it was in
jest because otherwise you know you're
gonna be sorely disappointed let's see
what else we got
I already talked about climate change
[Music]
ethics in relation to the technology
people are still asking about the Lewis
guitar e what else have we got people
wanting to go back and forth about
climate change a lot of back and forth
here well here we go mirror sharp so
we'll go out on this one would you
recommend to newbies in philosophy
reading original works by philosophers
or some kind of summaries like Russell's
history of philosophy
I recommend primary texts if you're
going to use secondary texts don't use
Russell Russell is sometimes okay
and sometimes crap Russell's full of
full of BS on some philosophers and you
know even worse would be like William
Durant's the the story of philosophy
which you can easily find in like you
know bookstores under the philosophy
section if you're going to do a history
of philosophy the safe bet is Friedrich
cobblestones history of philosophy
that's what we used in graduate school
it's he's usually not going to lead you
astray you know there's some more
contemporary ones but you know I think
read the original texts you can go back
to histories of philosophy later on but
but actually read Plato right it's not
something you have to like be afraid of
I don't know if I'm smart enough to read
Plato I need it predigested how do you
know that the person who you're actually
trusting has it rights
you don't until you read it for yourself
so you know start out in ancient
philosophy read some Plato
read some Aristotle I've got videos on
on where you might start and how to do
that you know I'm doing this whole
series on self-directed study in
philosophy but you know it's always
better to have some of those things
under your belt and and it can be a
smattering you like start with some
Plato then read some Nietzsche then jump
backwards and read some Descartes
you know it doesn't all have to be
sequential but you do want to have
engagement with the actual stuff not
just stand-ins that you can't actually
be sure are going to be correct for
yourself you need to find this out for
yourself
so here's where I'm going to end it
let's see where's the button for that
good questions from from everybody sorry
I didn't get to the some of them but
that's always the way it works in these
these sessions and have a great weekend